大学で大学20歳やってからずっとやってますので、僕も40年くらい生まれたって。
すごい。
今はね、当日の中学生とか教えたり、学生さん、中学生さん、中学生さん、障害を教えたり、
お待たせします。
こんにちは。
クラタグさん、クラタグさん、お話ししてます。
初めまして、よろしくお願いします。
クラタグさんは、絵を描くと。
忘れられ逆に行って。
絵を描いてたんですけど、馬術部が馬を連れて遊びに来てて、大学に。
で、馬の絵を描きなくて、馬術部に来たら馬がいっぱいいるよって言われて、絵を描きに馬術部に行ったら、そのまま入婦しちゃって。
すごい。
ずっと。
だから、馬に乗って、手入れして、絵を描いて。
また?
はい。また馬に乗って、絵を描いて。
で、こちらに来た時は、頭山とか。
すごい。
ずっと。
ずっと描いて。
へぇー。
素敵な。
すごい。
ずっと。
で、自分で、馬を買っているんですか?
いや、大学で。
大学?
はい。馬がたくさんいるんで。
あと、大学の小学、中学か。
中学校も、わつまの中学が、馬術部になっているので、中学生と高校生の教えていて。
中学生の部下と、大学に体育の授業で、馬術の授業。
はい、出ましたね。
うん。
馬術の授業がある大学が、あんまりない。
あんまりない。
人気なんです。
うーん、それそうですね。
すごい。
授業でた。
本当に、こういう体験があれば、
大学の授業で、
私は中心はコロンビアでコロンビアで馬を買いました
持ってたんですか?自分の馬ですか?
自分の馬です
それで今まで両方買いました
乗ってられたかな?
乗っているのは週末朝の夜まで山をすっと一緒に
まさに馬はあなたを連れて行く
夜になったら早く帰りたいと
そうじゃない?
試合の時もそうです
試合に出ても帰りたくても帰りたい
モンゴルとかもありますよね
一日草原を走って行けるに止まって
またずっと走って夜に行けるに止まって
永遠にモンゴルの草原を走るツアーとかあります
はいはいはいはいはい
うん
ロングスと一緒にやるスポートは
お前に行けるの?
うんうんうん
そうです
感じるの
あ
とてもお前に
ここに
残りたい
座りながら
はいはいはい
お友達も
いいんですよ
お友達も来て
ここでずーっと
夕方まで
夕方
知らったように
あとはずっと
ここで
ラッテルスといっぱいいます
とてもいい心地
ね
なあかんきゃあ
ロングシェア
ラッテルスといっぱい
やっていまして
素晴らしい
うわぁすごいですよね
うん
すごい乗られる
伸るんですよ
これとかあの
フランスで私の
これはフランスのね
サロン・ドーツーミーって
そういうところに
出しました
去年
すごい
10月に
展示会はいつもあって
今年も1枚出してます
うまく
はい
お札と
お札とお札になって
時間はそうなんです
はい
その頃はあまり乗ってなくて
結構厳しい学校の出張になって
そうですね
はい
ん
6年ぐらいちょっと抜けたんですけど
いろんなことになりました
ねえ、なかなかああいう形にはならないよね
肌のゆずにね 埋まって歩いたんですよ
これが素晴らしい
これは大きな手が入り口になったんだけど
これ今大学で白いのかもで買ったんで
そのまま見てるんですけどこのまま
出てきておりました
目がすごくすごい
この絵はね砂を混ぜたりして材質を作って
危ない砂を入れて
塵をしっかり作った上で描いてますので
ちょっと不思議な材質があると思うんですよ
ただキャンバスに色んな設定になるので
マッチー存在をちゃんと作れたり
すごい
今日やる皆さんどこですか?
泊まれるんですね?
泊まれないけど
今日は日帰りです
日帰りですか?
今日の家があったんだけど
私はね
はい
あったんだけど
一人になってから
あのー
そうなんですか?
はい
今日からの方?
夜ご飯を買えるんですよ?
あーもう帰れるんですよ?
うんうんうん、素晴らしいですよ。すごいですよ。
え?そう10年目前
えーとー
お前の
バジェチを
バジェチは大学の
バセダクという大学の
魔術部だったんですよ。
毎日上手にやってました。
大学時代。
で、障害を保存だり
うん。
あのー
総合バジェチ
森の中を走るような
距離を
やったりしてました。
わーすごい。
それがもう
とても面白くて
それから馬にはまりました。
うんうん。
これは一番
何ですか?
まあ今も
たまに乗ってまって
教えながら
ちょっと馬が
あたない時とか
変わってるんですね。
はい。
うん。
してますね。
うん
そう、理工だからね、乗った途端に
乗ったのかどうか分かるんですよね
そうなんですよね
まあ、またやっぱり、ごまん乗らなくて
まあ、ぜひね
乗りたいよね
これはね、馬の雑誌なんですけど
これ僕のあの
よく馬科学会ってとこで
公演をやってくれって言ってるんだけど
その時の公演で
これフランスのドートンヌの会長と
お話しした時の写真とか
これね、僕の若い時代です
生涯に富んでいる
まだ20代の
こういうのが
前の学生とか
商売を飛んでました
今はもう絵の方
中心ですけど
これはね、フランス遊び行った時の
フランスの牧場の
馬の雑誌の場合
うん
馬はね、外国行っても馬ばっかりはしてるんですけど
競馬場でこういう展示会であったりとか
これは僕が教えている馬術の授業の写真から
馬に乗ってる人がいて
はい、ほらいいですね
このぐらい学生がいて
毎週教えてもらう
うん
きれいよね
色はね、できるだけ発色のいい色を使う
うん
あまり混ぜない
実はこういうのが
ステンシルっていう方なんです
馬の型を作って
はい
色を乗せて
そうするときれいな馬の形だけが
彫り回るので
わー
馬のシルエットってすごいきれい
きれいですよね
はい
あの真ん中もそう、それもきれいです
馬は一世こう、グッと回ると
足をね、こうやってくるって
めっちゃかっこいいんですよね
うんうんうん
なかなかこう足が上がってこなくて
自分が
馬がこう
エネルギーがないで
こういう風には
上がってこないですけど
そうなったときはすごいきれいな形
うん
これすごいナイス
走り走っていくっていう
それを拝見してちょっと思い出したんですけど
娘が、ミスターが彼女の主人なんですけど
私の娘の
娘はバグバグ公園で
今の女性だと
動きの形状に
整形状とか
やってます
やっぱりやすいです
知ってます
すごい厳しい形で
僕が学生の時
いつも山谷先生が形状やって
子供たちが乗ってました
面白いやってました
もう
3000年くらい前かな
力ちゃんの年齢から考えると
私は
僕はよくバチコエってた頃です
本当にそう
たくさん持ってました
バタイマバとかでよく
ええ、もうしょっちゅう
山谷先生
大人に来てくれた
なんかもうだいぶお年なんで
そうですね
最近は
最近はなんか
返事が来なかったから
大丈夫かなと思ってたんだ
そう
山谷先生の息子さんに会いました
去年
ジュイさん
はい
私も知ってる
奥様も
そうですか
それはびっくりですよ
ところ
もう本当に
40年近く前になった
いろんな方の女の子が
増えてしまったんだけど
撮影してしまったんだけど、あの…
エイゾーはなんて言うか、話の時は、すごいんでしょ?
ちょっと、40年前です.
いぐらい前にね。
僕の知ってる人だと、新城さんってあるわけだろ。
新城さんはね、知ってます。
本当ですか、新城?
あれ?あれ?
どうですか?
新城さんはもう、世話になりました。
大学の時のコーチだから、全て教えて頂いて。
あー、そうですか。
新城さんがやってたのが、馬術の授業で、それを今、僕が教えてます。
はい、いいですね。
私はあんまり、あの、特に協議会に出ようとか、そういうのが目的ではなかったもんで、
結局、あの、第三科目までしかできなくて。
やっぱり、こっちの第三科目。
まあ、第三科目では出たことあるんですけど、でも、そんな…
ご視聴ありがとうございました。
思わなかったけど
千葉先生とか千葉見に教えてください
教えていただきました
いいよ
よく読ませていただきました
あ、そうか
まあ懐かしい
今も場で来いながらそんなに簡単に入れないし
でも、試合があれば解決して
千葉公園はちょっと行ってますけど
大学の試合があると
見に来ても
ちょうどその時千葉先生がやっちゃった
あと、おたるさんとか
おたるさんとか
なんか、おだるさんと言われて
本当に私たちとりゃ
できる
なんか、お花させなさいな
そうですね
それをやったし
ちょっとやるいま
大丈夫
いっ
誰か
たぶん
秋子さん
うん、秋子さん
たち
何まで書いていただきましたか
ぜひやる
また、ご案内します
ありがとうございます
東京の方に使う
今、東京なんですけど
その、家庁なんかやってた娘が今アメリカにする
ああ、おもちゃのほう
そう、おもちゃのほう
そう
あの、子供の3人はこれが仕組みなんだけど
3人いてやりたければやる
いいなって言って
じゃあ、おたるさんのおはような気持ちのほうが書いて
はい、はい。
インスタグラム。
どうぞ、やっててください。
ありがとうございます。インスタグラムある。
やってます。これも僕のタックスにしてます。
ありがとうございます。
馬は乗られないんですか?
いやー、すっごい昔子供の頃乗ったことあるんですけど。
でも、馬の家系ですから、皆さん。
全然。
いやー。
馬はね、見ると、あ、乗る。
でも、乗るより、一緒に生活する。
お世話して、えっと、何とか
シューマーキス、私はコロンビアでシューマーキス
で、シューマーキスは本当に必ず
乗らなくてもいいんです
父親もね、あの、ずっと、父親もこうやって
あれ、そうなんだ
私は、父親が好きなのは、えっと、
走れる、コロで、なんでかと言うと
ちょうばさ、これじゃないでしょ
えっと、日本語でいいんですよ
一緒にちょっと乗りましたよね、チェバでね
ひもで、つけて、えっと、ま、曲がる、曲がる
シュー、わからない日本語でと言いますか
チェバ作か
チェバ作、そう、チェバ作
チェバ作が、えっと、簡単にやるじゃない?
でも、これがオーマーの決まりです
とても、
ひもつけてないと、どこか行っちゃうんですよ
ちょうばさく、こうやってれば、自分は操作しなくても、同じ円運動で、こう、ぐるぐるぐる回ってくれるんで、そこで自分のバランスを練習するんですね
それが、非常に楽しい、非常に楽しい
それが、その後は、気分がいいときに、ジャンプして、なんとか嬉しい
ジャンプは、面白いです
ジャンプ
今は、最高で2mぐらいまで飛びますから、いい馬は
ジャンプは、その、ね、障害がないと、最高だと、高さになって、パーっと横に
オリンピックだと、160とか、このぐらいの障害までは、取れないと
それは大事です
いや、これで、筋肉とかエネルギーとか、すごい
うん
なんか、どうやって
あと、あの、最後まで、あの、元気で、お会いしてたの、あの、高山先生って、あの、パシャーかたのか、知ってられてました
たぶん、よく知ってますけど、そこで教えていただいて、されるくらい
もう少し。もう一回。車。
馬は疲れた時に教えまでしてるじゃない。
もういいから。
面白いですよね。
園長の女の子が一人も覚えたさないというのは必要だよね。どうしたんですか?
その当時は、新庄さんの前は誰だったんですか?
新庄さんは、ちょっと思いつかないですか?
新庄さんは、お腹の中になりまして、ライブ前に。
馬のトレーニングは、日本でどういう風に始まるのか?
高烈な施設に行けなければ、何か?
僕たちは、競馬は大体日本だと、走らせた馬をもらってきて、あるいは買ってきて、それをさっきの長馬作でどれどれ。
そうじゃないか。
まずは、長馬作をやるんですけど、最初は暴れますから。
そうですよね。
まず、長馬作でちゃんと回るように踏んで、それで人を乗せて、落とさがりかじるか、何度もやるんですよ。
クロスのボールを飛ばして、1個飛んだらまた次にまたクロスを作ってジャンプ、ジャンプ、ジャンプ、って3回くらいジャンプさせていく。
それを繰り返し繰り返し、とにかく教えるんですよね。
無理しないで、ひっくりしようからからやっていって、だんだん上げていって。飛んだら褒めて、ニージ上げて。
ここはだいたい人情者に座って、やり方全部座って、絶対引っ張られちゃダメだよ。
馬が飛んだら褒めて、飛んだら褒めて、それを繰り返すといいのができるから。
ゆっくりゆっくり、ちょうど。
急にこうやってバーを開けちゃうと、外で人を落ちて嫌なようにしちゃう。
飛べるような、ランダムと一回して。
そしたら、本当に。
そうです。
大きな恐怖がありました。
彼の車ですか?
この間ちょっと10日間も入院しちゃってたので
エイリーマンの上のカファに気にしてね
何時だけ迎えにしたいとか電話してとか
お客さんが来たので、あとは気に入りしてるんですけど
すごいという、担保
ありがとうございます
大丈夫?
見えない?
はい、助かったです
本当に共通のね、知り合いがいるもん
ナポレオンのポーズみたいな
かっこいい
ありがとうございます
おめでとうございました
お客さんの方が良さそうね
ちょっとなんかその
入院のあとちょっとなんかそうな感じに
障がんないね
大丈夫?
どうやってやられた方がいい?
大丈夫、それは大丈夫です
これ捕まわせて
はい
しょうがないよね、いつまでも
しょうがないよね
とてもこれでは馬乗れませんね
馬が歩いてくれます
歩いてくれます
浦田さん、ありがとうございます
はい、どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
どうも、嬉しちゃったね
嬉しちゃったね
いろんな方のお話しをしてたら
びっくりしました
私も
ん
原木の掩め物にしたものの時間
ご視聴ありがとうございました